Oh God
really really this is the foreshadowing
you want to start with I gave you a home
oh no now I'm my mom express yourself
however you want hi I'm grace topic no
now you know isn't it wonderful to be
part of a community in the know you
wouldn't know because that's not this
community we're dumb but self-aware just
like in the old days of me making videos
I went on my tumblr blog and I asked you
guys what kind of videos did you want to
see and a lot of you wanted to see more
how to adults videos where I try my best
to teach you the best way to be an adult
and a lot of you want to know how to go
back to college so I thought I would
combine them and give you a crash course
on how to adult in college if you're
going to college for the first time and
you're gonna go stay at college in a
dorm it can be very overwhelming so here
are some tips and tricks for dealing
with that first things first decorating
your dorm your dorm is a reflection of
you so you can decorate it however the
[ __ ] you want you live in America or you
don't either way
express yourself one of the easiest ways
is by resigning yourself to the fact
that you have eclectic style then
literally anything can be decorative
excuse me
here's a quick example of how to
decorate a blank space take a basket any
kind of basket this one's made of metal
put it on a table any kind of table that
one was there
then take some things to make you seem
more cultured than you are for having
them and put them in the basket a plant
will you pincers pieces throw it in
there then throw a throw on the chair
the throw gives color and texture and a
blanket for the people that you wish
hadn't stayed the night but did then how
about a throw pillow because this space
doesn't have enough goddamn personality
and last but not least the piece de
resistance whoa look at this space eat
your butt out HGTV here's another quick
tip you can buy these art campuses at a
craft store like Michaels for a few
dollars and then literally
anything you put on here is art for
example tada so cute now that at least
your side of the room looks great you
want to make sure that your stupid
roommate doesn't get anywhere near it so
time to step down juries the great thing
is that scientific stats have shown that
you will never ever ever rear oom with
your first college roommate so it's okay
to be a total bag of dicks to them
within reason and with rationales let's
set some super-cute boundaries I like to
take masking tape and then just kind of
drape it very casually across all of my
belongings while looking my piece of sh
roommate directly in the eyes
maintaining eye contact until they're
cute if you still don't think that human
taint is gonna get the picture then take
your super cute whiteboard planner that
you bought at Target because you're a
girl and you have to love stationery
even though you never use it because
your life is in shambles and leave your
roommate just a personal cute little
inspirational message oh my [ __ ] god
that is so big Pinterest now on to
college fashion clothing specifically
for your body for a college if you're in
it mostly and only but you can listen if
you're not just know that this isn't
meant for you so you you're stealing
this information from the people that
it's meant for at the college bodies
close your college students odds are
you're pretty broke unless you're one of
those kids born with a silver spoon up
the butthole you suck but if you're not
and you are on a budget here's the
formula that should help you out but
there's a fancy sweatpants let's the mix
of five relatively neutral colored and
bold patterned long-sleeve shirts short
sleeved shirts tank tops etc will get
you through an entire month of outfits
if not more
at some point they should be washed but
that's on you but if you're more of a
DIY type CEO is another video where I
show you how you can make really cool
clothes for very cheap and easy like a
lady of the night
yo hey food is another concern when
you're in college because we need food
to live and you need to live to get
through college so you need food and
food can be expensive and or difficult
to make here's something easy you can do
eat this stuff
here are some other essentials I highly
recommend you pick up before you head
back to college ones these one of these
one of these and all dish well there you
go there with my quick crash course on
college hopefully this was helpful to
you if it was give this video a thumbs
up leave me a comment and don't forget
to subscribe to this channel so that
these videos get into your life without
you being aware of it like welcomed
bedbugs I don't know great
that's passable just like a blunt ha ha
just kidding
I'm relating to you youth